bonjour à tous et tout on est en direct
sur brut rémy buisine depuis les locaux
de mediapart nous sommes avec fabrice
arfi edwy plenel qui viennent de tenir
il ya quelques instants une conférence
de presse quelques heures après la
tentative de perquisitions dans les
locaux du journal ce matin on va en
parler
d'ailleurs avec vous fabrice arfi parce
que vous étiez présent ce qui n'était
pas le cas des louise pennel parce que
vous vous étiez au tribunal c'est ce
tribunal de paris pour défendre
l'honneur du travail de mediapart face à
une plainte de denis baupin après nos
révélations c'était il y a près de trois
ans sur des faits d'agression et de
harcèlement sexuel
donc je répondais dans le cadre légal
nous ne sommes pas au-dessus de la loi
il ya une loi sur le droit de la presse
et quand on veut nous demander des
comptes on nous demande des comptes dans
le cadre de cette loi ou nous légitimons
notre travail ce qui s'est passé ce
matin pendant que j'étais absent ou
qu'ils ont tenté de faire pendant mon
absence n'a rien à voir
c'est au contraire une violation du
droit de la presse non je dis pour ceux
qui l'ont gagné étaient pas à partager
dirais qu'à poser vos questions et
certainement prendre quelques unes dans
ce direct avec vous fabrice arfi fabrice
arfi vous êtes responsable du pôle
enquête à mediapart
vous étiez présent ce matin est ce que
vous pouvez nous raconter comment ça
s'est déroulé je suis correspondait avec
mia jdanov du pôle enquête il se trouve
que le lundi matin il ya la grande
conférence de rédaction un peu d'eau
madère du journal où ça ne s'invente pas
on avait beaucoup discuté des dérives
liberticides du pouvoir en place sur le
droit de manifester la loi anti casseurs
et aussi les déclarations rohff du
président de la république au point sur
le droit de la presse et c'était
particulièrement inquiétant quand
soudain à 11h10 précisément à un
procureur de la république accompagné
par une deuxième procureur de la
république plus trois policiers dont un
commissaire divisionnaire de la brigade
criminelle excusez du peu
ont sonné à la porte de mediapart pour
dire c'est une perquisition
ce qui est inédit dans l'histoire du
journal ça n'est jamais arrivé en 11 ans
d'existence à mediapart que nous soyons
la cible et si j'ai aussi dit
la victime d'une tentative de
perquisitions nous avons échangé avec
michaël hajdenberg dont il dirige le
service des enquêtes avec moi avec les
représentants de l'autorité judiciaire
et policière qui nous ont expliqué
qu'ils agissaient dans le cadre d'une
enquête préliminaire qui venait d'être
ouverte par le parquet de paris pour
atteinte à l'intimité de la vie privée
de monsieur b nana suite aux révélations
que nous avions fait la semaine dernière
basé sur une dizaine de sources
indépendantes des documents inédits et
des enregistrements sonores qui en rien
de violer la vie privée de monsieur
benalla puisque nous révélions que
monsieur benalla et son acolyte monsieur
kraz avec qui il est mise en examen dans
la sphère des violences du 1er mai ont
violé leur contrôle judiciaire en se
rencontrant secrètement à paris le 26
juillet dernier pour imaginer la
destruction de pièces et de preuve dans
ce dossier qu'ils se sont réunis pour
parler du contrat russe un contrat
sécuritaire signés du temps monsieur
benalla était à l'elysée avec
l'implication personnelle de monsieur
benalla pendant qu'il était à l'elysée
avec un oligarque russe proche de
vladimir poutine est liée d'après
plusieurs magistrats à la mafia
moscovite et au parjure d2 crasé benalla
devant le sénat puisqu'il on nier que
monsieur benalla et le moindre lien dans
ce contrat russe qui relève de la sphère
d'état et nous prouvions tout ça et
quelle a été la décision du parquet de
paris
c'est devenir perquisitionné mediapart
dans une enquête ouverte en défense de
monsieur de bédanne a au nom soit disant
de la violation de sa vie privée et des
moyens par lesquels aurait été capté les
enregistrements que nous avons révélé
alors mediapart n'a absolument rien
enregistré évidemment et comme le droit
nous ne le permet nous avons refusé
la perquisition le procureur de la
république nous a fait savoir qu'il
pouvait revenir on ne sait pas s'il va
le faire ou pas avec un mandat d'un juge
des libertés et de la détention jld
l'idée qui du coup rendrait la
perquisition contraignante et
coercitives donc là pour l'instant nous
sommes en suspens de ce point de vue là
mais dans un acte suffisamment grave qui
n'a qu'un seul objectif de notre point
de vue qu'un seul sait trouver les
sources de médias perte de mediapart
pour mettre un terme à cette enquête sur
le contrat bus sur les violences du 1er
mai et surtout sur le contrat russe qui
fait paniquer la présidence de la
république monsieur mettez donc ce matin
donc quand les policiers sont venus vous
avez pu refuser leur leur carte qui lui
ont apporté avec eux certains font de
comparatifs à ce qui a pu se passer
notamment en octobre dernier dans le
siège de la française céline est serré
mais dans ce cas-là différents l'armée
pourrait bien sûr alors va te servir
vers un peu de droit et ça peut être un
petit dieu pour ceux qui nous regardent
mais c'est très important
en fait le statut de lankaise qui a été
ouverte en catastrophe par le parquet de
paris en défense de monsieur benalla
c'est une enquête préliminaire ça veut
dire qu'elle est dirigée par le
procureur de la république de paris qui
est un magistrat kiné qui est soumis
hiérarchiquement est statutairement au
pouvoir exécutif en france ça n'est pas
une enquête qui est sous la conduite
d'un juge d'instruction qui lui juge du
siège est un juge indépendant du pouvoir
exécutif dans le cadre d'une enquête
préliminaire
la personne visée par une perquisition
peut la refuser
il peut la refuser préalablement pour
qu'elle n'ait pas lieu
mais le procureur peut aller chercher un
mandat d'un juge indépendant
un juge des libertés et de la détention
pour forcer forcer les portes de
mediapart et forcer la perquisition
c'est ce que nous a fait comprendre le
procureur de la république qui nous a
dit qu'ils pouvaient revenir qu'il n'a
pas exclu et j'ajoute que le
des libertés et de la détention qui en
l'occurrence n'a pas été saisie c'est
une des grandes différences avec les
perquisitions dans le cadre de la france
insoumise il juge aussi de la légitimité
des perquisitions par rapport au fait
est-ce que les l'intérêt public des
faits je rappelle que là nous sommes sur
une enquête préliminaire pour atteinte à
l'intimité de la vie privée
nous ne sommes pas sur des faits de
corruption nous ne sommes pas sur des
faits de financement illicite de parti
politique
nous ne sommes pas sur des faits qui je
ne juge pas mais jeudi le type de faits
qui nous seraient reprochés et en
l'occurrence nous n'avons violé
l'intimité de personnes
les propos que nous rapportons de
monsieur ben ali monsieur crasse ne
concerne pas leur vie privée mais leurs
affaires la présidence de la république
leur conflit d'intérêts la question des
pressions sur la justice
et surtout il y a vraiment un vrai
problème juridique que nous avons
soulevés à cette conférence de presse le
parquet a fait un communiqué cet après
midi où il dit qu'en fait c'est sur
initiative qu'il a ouverts de lui-même
cette enquête préliminaire pour
violation atteinte à l'intimité de la
vie privée donc il y a un vrai problème
pour qu'il y ait une atteinte à la vie
privée
il faut que la personne dont la vie
privée aurait été atteinte en témoigne
il faut qu'elle soit compagnon de la
justice parce que c'est elle qui sait ce
qu'est sa vie privée autant que je sache
le procureur de la république ne connais
pas la vie privée de monsieur ben ali
autant que je sache il n'est pas son
défenseur
autant que je sache il n'est pas à son
service et donc il est sidérant
et de ce point de vue cette tentative
est peut-être juridiquement nul
il est sidérant de vouloir qui plus est
a tenté à une liberté fondamentale celle
encore une fois d'un journal du
journaliste du droit de savoir
au nom de ce délit que nous n'avons pas
commis qui serait l'atteinte à
l'intimité de la vie privée sans même
que la victime potentielle cents soit
plainte sans même qu'elle ait dit j'ai
un délit
etc nous connaissons bien ce sujet
mediapart
on nous a mis en cause sur une longue
procédure judiciaire mais sans
perquisition il y avait des longues
batailles dans la sphère des
enregistrements bettencourt
la vie privée de madame bettencourt
liliane bettencourt la milliardaire
nous avons montré jusqu'à être relaxé
jusqu'à est reconnue dans notre mission
d'intérêt général que nous n'avions
évidemment pas violer l'intimité de la
vie privée de madame bettencourt je n'ai
pas mis de micros chez elle et que ce
que nous avions révélé était d'intérêt
public permettait de la protéger des
abus par rapport à sa situation de
faiblesse qui étaient commis contre elle
et par rapport à tout ce qui essayait de
s'enrichir indûment en commettant des
délits autour d'elle c'est ça le droit
de la presse le droit de la presse c'est
encore une fois on juge de ce que vous
publiez la légitimité de ce que vous
publiez
le sérieux de l'anc est la bonne foi du
travail le respect du contradictoire
monsieur benalla est tout à fait en
droit de poursuivre médiapart en
diffamation il est tout à fait en droit
de nous demander des comptes dans ce
cadre là bien sûr et nous répondrons
comme j'étais ce matin en train de
répondre dans la sphère beaupain sais
c'est le code de la route dans une
démocratie que le parquet rappelons le
qui n'est pas une magistrature
indépendante qui dépend du pouvoir
exécutif qui plus est
le parquet de paris dans sa nouvelle
configuration avec un procureur de la
république qui a été nommé par choix
personnel du président de la république
emmanuel macron lui même les trois
candidats pour ce poste qui avait été
retenu par le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature par la collégialité de la
profession et entendu est accepté comme
trois candidats faisant la faire par la
garde des sceaux elle même par le
premier ministre lui-même
ces trois là ont été faits du prince
rejetée par monsieur macron qui a choisi
l'actuel procureur mesurer miettes dont
le premier actions d'éclat et sept
tentatives
deux perquisitions dans un journal on
sait qu'un média pas vous avez révélé
régulièrement des affaires vont pas
justement de 2
j'ai pu avoir à plusieurs reprises est
ce que c'est la première fois qu'il ya
une perquisition dans les locaux bien
sûr bien sûr
vous savez dans beaucoup de tafer
notamment révélé par fabrice et toute
l'équipe d'investigation qu'il anime
avec michaël hajdenberg nous mettons des
preuves vous savez nous sommes un
journal du xxième siècle comme brut est
un média du 21e siècle
donc nous avant dans la presse on avait
des documents écrits imprimés ou
polycopiés ou des notes
bon aujourd'hui notre matériau c'est
aussi bien des vidéos que des sons
d'ailleurs la sphère benalla elle
démarre avec des vidéos des personnes se
posent la question de l'origine de ces
vidéos l'important c'est ce que montrent
ces vidéos les violences policières
commises par messieurs benalla écrase
contre des opposants politiques
pacifiques pour nombre d'entre eux on le
voit notamment au jardin des plantes
dans les vidéos que nous avons révélé
donc l'élément matériel que nous mettons
sur la table les sons des textes des
documents des images des vidéos
c'est ça que nous faisons comme travail
et quand la justice est concerné par ce
que nous révélons qu'est ce qu'elle nous
dit elle nous envoie une réquisition et
me dit ça nous intéresse pour notre
dossier judiciaire d'avoir la pièce
elle-même est un général à médiapart
nous l'avons fait dans l' enquête
libyenne quand nous publions le document
libyen qui est l'image d'un document
libyen qui vaut aujourd'hui à monsieur
sarkozy d'être mis en examen et
mediapart a gagné sa bataille vous le
savez récemment la cour de cassation
ce document n'est ni un faux matériel ni
un fonds intellectuelle eh bien nous le
transmettons à la justice nous ne
répondons pas aux questions sur son
origine secret des sources
mais nous le transmettons donc nous
donnons le dock les documents bruts qui
sont au coeur de notre travail
de fait les juges d'instruction de la
sphère benalla juge indépendant dès
vendredi nous ont transmis via un
commandant de police une demande nous
voudrions les enregistrements fabrice
arfi ce matin comme c'était convenu à 9h
a répondu comment on se met d'accord on
va vous remettre les enregistrements
avec des éléments de contextualisations
montre
l'authenticité de la date de ces
enregistrements
c'est à dire au jour du 26 juillet
montrant qu'ils sont en train de violer
leur contrôle judiciaire de se concerter
alors qu'ils n'en n'ont pas le droit je
rappelle que quand on n'y compte romney
dans un contrôle judiciaire c'est que l'
enquête judiciaire estime que les
personnes ne doivent pas se rencontrer
pour ne pas étouffer des preuves pour ne
pas maquillé le dossier pour ne pas
faire pression sur des témoins si ils se
rencontrent la juge étant le juge sont
en droit et c'est ce qui est prévu en
saisissant justement le fameux jld dont
nous parlons tout à l'heure de mettre
fin à quoi à leur liberté de les mettre
en détention pour éviter qu'ils
continuent à manipuler la justice
vous savez le parquet aurait pu très
bien vendredi en voyant ce que révélait
médias pinte
le parquet est maître des poursuites le
marquer et gardiens de l'ordre public on
nous le rappelle assez en ces temps de
manifestations et de condamnation
massive des gilet jaune est bien qu'est
ce qu'il fait il dit c'est un désordre
qui révéla et bien je fais un
réquisitoire supplétif ou juge pour
qu'il puisse aussi élargir leur saisine
sur des faits potentiel à eux de les
vérifier de violation du contrôle
judiciaire il n'a pas fait ça le parquet
j'ai une question que je vous pose et à
tous les deux tours à tours
je commence ce ver vous monsieur plenel
est ce que pour vous c'est une tentative
de l'état de vouloir faire taire
mediapart de vouloir toucher à vos
travaux source
c'est évidemment une atteinte ou secret
des sources et ce qu'ils cherchent c'est
l'origine de cet enregistrement
mais ce que je joue moins vous savez non
comment dire on s'est donné les moyens
de notre indépendance on prend ça avec
philosophie calme détermination et on va
continuer à faire notre travail grâce au
soutien du public
mais je pense que le public devrait
entendre là que c'est pas notre liberté
qu'on défend c'est une liberté plus
fondamental ce que nous on aime bien
mediapart appelé le droit de savoir le
droit de savoir tout ce qui est
d'intérêt public
en effet il y a actuellement une dérive
au coeur de l'appareil d'état au coeur
de certaines institutions et je lirai au
sommet de l'état en la personne du
président de la république qui est au
fond d'essayer de m
côté d'affaiblir de discréditer voire
d'entraver une presse qui dérange la
presse c'est le pluralisme et il faut
une presse qui d'errance il ya une
ironie dans toute cette affaire quand
monsieur maquereau en juillet a défendu
alexandre benalla c'est la fois où il a
dit qu'il vienne le chercher en dix ans
le responsable c'est moi
1 devant tout comme un chef de clan face
à ces parlementaires il a eu cette
phrase très étonnante
nous avons une presse qui ne cherche
plus la vérité c'est une antiphrase en
fait il parlait de nous c'est à dire
d'une presse qui cherche la vérité que
lui lui et la présidence de la
république n'ont cessé de dissimuler
dans cette affaire vous savez les
passeports diplomatiques c'est médiapart
il n'y en aurait pas su le jardin des
plantes qui montrent qu'il n'y a pas eu
aucune violence mais plusieurs violences
volontaires répéter c'est médiapart
de là le scandale immense immense et qui
pose des question abyssale de du contrat
russe de ce proche oligarques
ce proche de monsieur poutine alors que
monsieur crasse et permanent de la
république en marche alors que monsieur
benalla est l'homme de la sécurité le
plus proche de président de la
république lui-même alors komba les
oreilles avec eux les médias russes
l'intoxication russe etc et là on est au
coeur de la présidence 1 où se passent
les choses
et bien tout cela on n'aurait pas su
s'en mediapart
donc vous savez ce que j'ai envie de
dire abonnez vous nous mettons de verre
vers vous avec sa fille avec avec cette
même question pour vous est ce qu'ils
aient une influence du pouvoir danser
perquisition ce matin est ce que vous
sentez que il ya une pression venant
voilà du gouvernement du président la
pluie qui éventuellement sur votre
travail sur la sphère benalla on
rappelle que vous a dit que c'est une
affaire d'état
oui notamment dans son volet plus c'est
une affaire de l'état et c'est une
affaire d'état
ce n'est pas de moindre doute là dessus
ce qu'on peut dire qu'actuellement c'est
assez simple c'est que le parquet de
paris soumis hiérarchiquement au pouvoir
exécutif dirigé par un homme dans des
conditions qui a été nommé dans des
conditions qui ont fait bondir tous les
chroniqueurs judiciaires les syndicats
de la magistrature tant que tant que
cela n'apparaît
specter l'indépendance de la
magistrature a décidé plutôt que de se
soucier du fonds des faits que nous
avons révélé la semaine dernière de
l'intimité de la vie privée de monsieur
benalla qui en rien n'a été violée
dans cette affaire il a préféré se
ouvrir une enquête en défense de
monsieur benalla plutôt que de constater
avec nous que des délits ont été commis
par lui depuis ses premières mises en
cause après les révélations du monde
puis de médiapart dans la sphère du 1er
mai puis dans les révélations de
médiapart dans la sphère du contrat
russe donc on nous sommes dans une
situation aujourd'hui un pouvoir
judiciaire soumis au pouvoir politique a
décidé de mener une perquisition dans un
journal avec un seul objectif trouver
nos sources trouver les sources des
journalistes est pas notre petit
privilèges corporatistes
c'est à rire les informations qu'ils
nourrissent le débat public qui
nourrissent les citoyens c'est ce bien
commun immatériel qui permet d'alimenter
la conversation démocratique si vous
touchez aux sources des journalistes
vous n'avez plus que la com officielle
du gouvernement des entreprises des
syndicats peu importe nous on est là
pour dire les faits y compris les faits
qui dérange et manifestement depuis le
début dans la ferme et dallas il y en a
au sommet de l'état qui ne veulent pas
que nous poursuivions nos investigations
c'est une atteinte à la liberté de la
presse pour vous qui arrive bien sûr ni
bien sûr c'est une nouvelle dérive vous
savez il ya eu beaucoup de choses qui
sont passés la loi sur le secret des
affaires
la loi dite sur les fausses nouvelles et
puis cette décision de dire dont il faut
un conseil de presse pour juger
déontologiquement les journalistes
toute cette façon de se dire attendez il
faudrait pas au contraire donner des
droits aux rédactions pour qu'elle soit
indépendante pour qu'elles défendent
leur indépendance
il ne faudrait pas au contraire faire
l'éloge d'une presse libre et
indépendante comme on dit dans le débat
américain fruit indépendante presse il
ne faudrait pas au contraire dire que
heureusement qu'on a ce bouillonnement
de la presse et bien non on a un
discours qui est partagée hélas par
certains opposants du pouvoir politique
actuel de critiques permanentes notre
travail au lieu de voir cette légitimité
de ce travail et là vous voyez bien que
ce encore une fois la critique des
médias est légitime mais un rejet
global du journalisme c'est donner la
main à ses pouvoirs qui vont utiliser ce
rejet global compte vos libertés pas
seulement les nôtres les vôtres votre
droit de savoir
donc nous journalistes nous défendons
cette indépendance
on dit souvent vous savez la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme dit le
journaliste c'est en anglais en c'est
plus agréable le watchdog le chien de
garde en anglais watchdog c'est le chien
qui regarde qui qui regarde ce qui se
passe le chien de garde c'est nous
sommes
selon la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme nous devons être nous devons
être quand nous ne sommes pas des
journalistes de cours de commentaires
quand nous faisons notre travail au
service du public des chiens de garde de
la démocratie alors c'est quoi un chien
de garde
il peut avoir de la bave à la gueule il
peut être pas sympathique
il peut envoyer à pas d'heure que nous
dit la cour des droits de l'homme sait
qu'il vaut mieux ce désordre que le
grand silence ou du coup on ne sait plus
rien du coup on est prisonnier des
propagandes des idéologies des mensonges
en un mot la seule question qui se pose
à nous c est ce que ce que nous écrivons
est vrai ou faux ce que nous écrivons
est vrai et c'est ce qui dérange
est-ce qu'on peut pas une justice à deux
vitesses il a beaucoup dans les
commentaires qui nous en parle
actuellement en dix ans on a
l'impression qu'il ya une justice qui
opère différemment sur le cas bénins que
sur d'autres et justiciables bien tu as
aimé ça c'est une comme la lettre volée
d'edgar allan poe c'est sous nos yeux
c'est sur la cheminée penser que quand
la sphère beynat la saison c'est à dire
les violences policières étaient sous le
seul contrôle du parquet de paris
quand ils ont tenté de perquisitionner
le domicile de monsieur benalla ils ont
une 48 heures pour perquisitionner le
domicile de monsieur benalla parce qu'il
n'avait pas la clé n'ont pas appelé
ainsi relier n'ont pas forcé la pac
monsieur ben alors lafarge année de la
langue dit refuser d'ouvrir banc dans
l'intervalle de ses 48 heures que s'est
il passé
un coffre fort le chambre forte présente
dans le domicile de monsieur benalla a
été subtilisé par on ne sait pas qui qui
pouvait contenir des pièces intéressant
l'enquète à la manifestation de la
vérité monsieur benalla a reconnu sur
procès verbal que des gens étaient venus
faire le ménage avant la perquisition le
parquet de paris n'a pas élargi son
enquête à cette destruction de preuves
cette disparition de preuves en revanche
nous révélons une affaire d'état avec
les ingérences
us auprès de monsieur benalla pendant
qu'il était à la présidence de la
république la violation de son contrôle
judiciaire
son parjure avec monsieur crasse devant
la commission d' enquête du sénat est la
première réaction du parquet de paris
c'est de venir nous perquisitionné pour
trouver nos sources il est impossible de
ne pas souscrire à l'idée que dans la
ferme et nana il y a une justice du
procureur de la république à deux
vitesses quelle suite vous allez donner
maintenant edwy plenel d'abord comme ça
a été a expliqué à la conférence de
presse nos avocats ont fait diligence
pour remettre les éléments documenté que
nous avions révélé dans cet article au
juge d'instruction faire savoir au
parquet et derrière le parquet a au juge
des libertés ici le parquet avait
l'intention de le saisir pour poursuivre
dans son intention de nous
perquisitionné et pour dire écoutez
fermez le ban fermez le ban les pièces
de médias pain sont aux mains de la
justice
il n'y a aucune raison que vous vous
entêtez pied inviolée ce ne peuvent
avoir accès à cela sent venir bien sûr
il y assure bien sûr s'il se perd si
c'est que c'est pas ça qui les intéresse
c'est pas le fond qui les intéresse
c'est tout ça vient et s'il s'intéresse
à d'où ça vient
c'est s'intéressent à nos sources secret
qui est encore une fois nous s'il y a
quelque chose comme journaliste que nous
devons protéger ses les sources c'est
elle qui nous font travailler c'est elle
qui nous alerte et toutes celles et tous
ceux qui nous écoutent le savent sont
des lanceurs d'alert et si vous vous
rendez compte des journalistes qui
dirait ah oui quand je vous dis qu'il
m'a parlé et je tremble pas ce que vous
venez me perquisitionné donc je vous dis
bah non nous plutôt plutôt se faire
découper en rondelles que de dire quoi
que ce soit sur nos sources c'est c'est
le secret des secrets tiens vraiment
c'est comme si nous rompions le contrat
de confiance avec le public lui même qui
nous alerte après c'est notre travail
peut-être qu'une alerte n'est pas
suffisante qu'il faut recouper qu'il
faut vérifier ça veut dire parfois il ya
des gens qui nous donnent des affaires
qui nous alerte sur des affaires et puis
on dit ben non on ne peut pas publiés ça
tient pas où on n'a pas suffisamment de
choses etc
mais ça c'est notre travail et nous
prenons notre responsabilité encore une
fois nous nous rendons compte de ce que
nous publions est-ce que vous avez un
message aujourd'hui peut-être mac
tof castaner au ministère de l'intérieur
vis-à-vis de douala de ce qui s'est
produit aujourd'hui à l'elysée à
l'elysée pour vous mais non mais la
question c'est l'elysée l'homme qui a
d'un trait de plume refuser les
procureurs que le conseil supérieur de
la magistrature la ministre de la
justice est le premier ministre
soumettez pour le poste du parquet de
paris c'est le président de la
république qui fait une espèce de
justice qu'ils décident par fait du
prince à sa main dont nous voyons dont
nous voyons bien là l'efficacité du
point de vue qui est le sien donc le
seul message qui à dire à monsieur
macron qui a dit en effet le 24 juillet
dernier dans son discours sidérant à la
maison de l'amérique latine dans lequel
il a mis en cause le parlement la
justice et la presse en disant les
journalistes ne cherche plus la vérité
bien que nous n'allons pas arrêter de
faire notre métier c'est au contraire
chercher la vérité y compris celles qui
le dérange
moi je voudrais faire un message plutôt
à au public nous nous sommes au service
du public
c'est ça notre indépendance c'est ça
notre garantie vous savez on a une
formule mediapart seuls nos lecteurs
peuvent nous acheter et je voudrais
parmi ce public et divers qui est varié
qui a ses sensibilités
et on le voit bien sûr dans les
mouvements sociaux actuels notamment le
mouvement des gilets jaunes faudrait
dire à tous ceux qui partagent ce que
nous défendons à mediapart une
république démocratique et sociale plus
de démocratie
une république vraiment délibérative une
république plus parlementaire une
république où le pouvoir personnel ne
confisque pas à la volonté de tous qui
partagent aussi ses idéaux d'égalité de
droits et bien leur dire vous voyez ce
journalisme qui parfois vous dérange qui
parfois vous bouscule qui parfois est
insuffisant et vous savez bien que
mediapart mène ce combat aussi bien au
sein du journalisme et parfois compte
certains journalistes un peu trop
complaisant un peu trop suiviste et bien
cette profession il ne faut pas la jeter
avec l'eau du bain
cette profession elle est utile et
nécessaire nous nous sommes des
travailleurs de l'information comme il y
à des travailleurs d'autres métiers donc
voila moi c'est un appel plutôt à cette
alliance
plutôt que à ce divorce parce que cette
elle est au coeur encore une fois
de tout ce qui est débattu tous les
samedis aujourd'hui dans des
manifestations dans des ronds points
ce sont des enjeux très importants et
nous nous espérons que tous ces enjeux
iront du côté d'une exigence
démocratique d'une exigence sociale et
non pas vers ce que nous dénonçons la
des dérives autoritaires des dérives
verticales des dérives confiscatoire du
bien commun laissez cela quelles que
soient les étiquettes politiques
elles ont beaucoup de visages dans le
monde actuel et bien c'est contre ces
dérives qu'il faut se serrer les coudes
et voilà voilà ce que ce que j'ai envie
de dire moi voilà nommé ce notre message
il est au public que monsieur castaner
que monsieur edouard philippe que
monsieur emmanuel macron l'entendent
mais l'entendre c'est pas seulement
entendre mediapart c'est entendre ce qui
sourd du pays aujourd'hui par rapport à
cette promesse qu'il avait faite il y a
deux ans d'une révolution démocratique
profonde
on en est loin avec ce qui va être voté
demain au parlement sur les droits de
manifester
on en est loin avec mediapart l'a
beaucoup documenté avec david dufresne
avec le niveau de violences policières
c'est pas du maintien de l'ordre ça
c'est de la répression
on en est loin avec beaucoup trop de
mépris vis-à-vis des gens du peuple
vis-à-vis de la diversité de notre
peuple
c'est ça le vrai enjeu et vous voyez
bien que dans ce contexte si on ne
défend pas un tel parce qu'on se dit je
n'aime pas trop parce que c'est pas trop
ma kospi qu'un et qu'on s'aperçoit pas
gelé pas défendu mais tiens c'est mon
tour donc c'est là où il faut comprendre
que toutes les libertés se tiennent et
que nous devons faire front ensemble de
la question justement avec 2 contient
soleil notamment
est-ce que vous subissez des pressions
ce que vous sentez vous sous pression
fabrice à la meilleure réponse là dessus
dit ben oui tu dis toujours on s'est
donné les moyens
cessionnaire et 20 blessés pas je vais
citer alors la morale du boxeur dont on
donne des cours soit des coups mais sa
démocratie ça se passe dans un cadre qui
est prévue à cet effet bien sûr que on
publie des informations qui dérange et
c'est normal que nous ayons à être
poursuivis devant la justice si les gens
s'estime diffamée on n'est pas au dessus
des lois mais il ya une loi qui est
prévue à cet effet depuis 1880 et c'est
le seul cadre général le seul qu'un code
de la route dans le cadre duquel nous
revendiquons l'exercice de notre
profession et notre déontologie et de
respect de de la loire alors est ce
qu'il ya des pressions a depuis 11 ans à
mediapart oui on a connu toutes sortes
de pressions
on a connu la calomnie verbale on a été
traités de journal aux méthodes
fascistes sous nicolas sarkozy nous
avons été espionnés nous avons été
cambriolés
nous avons été menacés aujourd'hui nous
connaissons une violence symbolique
puisqu'il faut bien mettre les mots sur
les choses
une violence symbolique qui vient de
l'état lui même de l'appareil judiciaire
lui même qui consiste le redis à venir
perquisitionné un journal pour trouver
ces sources et empêcher la poursuite
d'une enquête qui met dans la plus
grande difficulté un ancien
collaborateur du président de la
république dont on ne sait pas si le
président de la république a pris ses
distances avec lui le directeur cabinet
du président oui le président je ne sais
pas dans une affaire notamment la sphère
du contrat russe qui encore une fois est
autrement plus grave
autrement plus graves que beaucoup de ce
goût de quoi le gouvernement voudrait
qu'on parle nous parlons d'un monsieur
benalla au coeur de l'elysée qui a
négocié avec un oligarque russe proche
de monsieur poutine alors qu'il était à
la présidence de la république est
dépositaire de ses secrets c'est une
question financière c'est une pression
potentielle des compromissions de l'état
donc on voit bien que la réaction et la
violence symbolique du parquet de paris
qui a voulu nous perquisitionné est en
europe est en réalité à la mesure de la
gravité des faits que nous révélons et
ce qu'ils cherchent c'est à terre non
pas d'éventuels délits que nous aurions
commis auquel nous ont participé mais
ses terres la vérité ça il en est hors
de question justement pour pour conclure
manière cette dernière image y
travaillant que avant de vous libérer
vous remercie en tout cas d'avoir
accordé cette interview exclusive à brut
on parle beaucoup en ce moment voilà de
la défiance envers les joints sont vers
l'est
dir de par votre carrière est ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous ressentez
comme inédit à son niveau et qui aussi
qu'ils sont comme on peut répondre à ça
comme on pas réussi à réconcilier entre
guillemets le peuple et la presse je
vais vous faire une double réponse ce
qui est inédit
il ya toujours eu un des campagnes d
attaque et c'est ce qui est inédit c'est
que des responsables au plus haut niveau
de la politique soit des gens qui sont
en affaire soit des gens qui souhaitent
être aux affaires donne le feu vert à la
haine du journalisme ça c'est inédit
ça c'est inédit ca c c'est scandaleux
le président de la république et
gardiens de la constitution ne peut pas
dire nous avons une presse qui ne
cherche plus la vérité alors que lui il
n'arrête pas d'étouffer la vérité je
rappelle que pendant deux mois ils ont
étouffé la sphère benalla et on se
disant ça va pas se savoir et on va le
garder à l'elysée malgré ce qu'il a fait
et il a même demandé début novembre de
l'indulgence pour ben à l'afp quand même
il ya ensuite les passeports
diplomatiques les voyages et c'est sans
compter un climat vous savez on l'a eue
pendant la campagne présidentielle aussi
bien à droite aussi bien dans une partie
de la gauche aussi bien dans le pouvoir
actuel
il y à ce feu vert qui est donnée à la
dévalorisation du travail du journaliste
encore une fois nous notre position
c'est qu'il y à une critique du
journalisme qui est non seulement
légitime mais nécessaire c'est un débat
nécessaire et nous l'avons entre
journalistes et nous l'avons dans notre
profession qui est pluraliste
en revanche la disqualification en bloc
d'une profession là ce n'est pas la
haine du journalisme en l'occurrence
c'est la démocratie que l'on discrédite
car c'est un droit fondamental vous
savez nous sommes près de la place de la
bastille je le dis toujours il ya une
colonne la colonne de juillet les trois
glorieuses et dieu sait si dans
l'imaginaire des gilet jaune c'était
présent les trois glorieuses de juillet
1830 c'est des gens de ce quartier ciq
était le quartier le plus populaire de
il le faubourg saint-antoine qui ont
donné leur vie alors qu'il y avait le
travail des enfants alors qu'ils avaient
pas le repos du dimanche alors qu'ils
n'avaient pas les pots si la retraite va
y avait pas tous ces droits sociaux et
bien c'est pas pour ça qu'ils ont donné
leur vie ils sont 500 des poules sur
cette colonne ils ont donné leur vie
pour le droit de la presse contre les
ordonnances de charles dit ce qu'ils
voulaient limiter un droit qui était
pourtant balbutiant au point que cette
révolution de 1830 pendant un moment on
a appelé la révolution des journalistes
alors certains de ses journalistes sont
devenus son passé du côté obscur de la
force après mais d'autres comme charles
delécluse comme d'autres figures ont
continué à défendre les idéaux
démocratiques et sociaux donc voila
voila le pour moi le le changement c'est
celui-là et kir et en écho à une époque
c'est monsieur erdogan qui met en prison
des journalistes qui trouvent plus
dangereux que ses opposants politiques
c'est en russie des journalistes qui
sont assassinés c'est des journalistes
indépendants qui sont carrément mis au
pas chez monsieur orban hongrie 1 comme
s'ils étaient des agents d'une puissance
étrangère
c'est monsieur trump qui insulte par
tweet toute la journée ou à peu près
l'ensemble des journalistes indépendants
qui me déplaisent c'est monsieur ball
zone euro qui refusent une presse
d'enquêté d'investigation alors au
brésil alors qu'il y à une enquête qui
met en cause son fils et ainsi de suite
donc si nous voulons défendre notre
démocratie si vous voulons défendre non
pas une république autoritaire non pas
une république dont le président serait
le propriétaire mais une république de
tous bien il faut défendre tous ses
droits le droit de manifester le droit
de la presse le droit d'association le
droit d'inventer tous ses droits sans
lier voilà et c'est là que se joue la
confiance pour moi la confiance c'est un
journalisme qui est au service du public
qui rend compte au public nous sommes un
média participatif mediapart
on a le droit de nous critiquer dans les
blocs de médiapart
on a le droit de nous contester et ça
arrive parfois nous n'avons pas le
dernier mot mais c'est comme ça que se
construit dans ce dialogue nous nous
sommes dans cette culture de
l'horizontalité démocratique mais je
redis encore une fois la leçon de cette
affaire c'est que attention attention à
force
de laisser faire des polémiques des
entorses des virulence contre la
légitimité de la profession de
journaliste on laisse faire des choses
comme ça et c'est ça cette alerte qui
concerne tout le monde pas que la
profession de journaliste
merci beaucoup edwy plenel et fabrice
arfi d'avoir accepté de répondre on
excuse et à mes questions pour on
retrouve bien sûr l'ensemble de vos
contenus sur médiator media.fr et
abonnez vous merci beaucoup
voilà on termine et on termine ce direct
dans les locaux de médiapart donc cette
demi heure du terme vous pourrez
retrouver est bien en replay en
intégralité dans quelques instants
merci à vous merci c'était un ami visite
pour vous depuis le comédien pas